season five oh sorry what isn't that
worth it
welcome back a lot has changed I'm
within New York there's Annie she's
helping produce the show anyway so this
is an episode that I put together for
your return to Los Angeles we're gonna
be trying three large-format meets at
three drastically different price points
to find out which one is the most worth
it at it's a given price what is it
oftentimes on menus you'll see your
appetizer section your entrees sometimes
there's an extra special bonus zone
where there is a very expensive intended
to be shared dish and that's kind of
what inspired this episode eating big
stuff like this you need friends why not
eat that with my friends in this car
today
yes that was my idea that's not a novel
no I just came up with that just now it
was the whole point of this whole
excursion my name is David Koh and I'm
chef/owner of little fatty an accomplice
bar today we're gonna be eating Chinese
barbecue pork what kind of place is
little fatty it definitely appeals to
like you're old-school chinese-american
Hallett done with a little twist
we have walnut shrimp we have orange
chicken we also do like super authentic
stuff like right now we have gone down
Mia and we used the chinese-american as
like a gateway drug it gets you in the
door but then you start ordering this
other stuff and then you trust us and
order more stuff we're attached to a bar
yeah what's with that it's kind of
unique to get craft cocktails or
mixology with Chinese food I think
that's what sets us apart what's your
favorite drink on that menu right now I
think it's the pearl diver it's like
this macadamia nut rum and brown butter
and sugar mix you could put on pancakes
oh good so this barbecue pork what piece
of work is this knee it's called like a
pork hock I love taking like
underutilized cut of meat and turn it to
something magical I think that's the
beauty of cooking we use a combination
of Shao Shang soy sauce ginger garlic
and how long does that braise for about
four or five hours let it sit overnight
and then we air dry and like Peking duck
so he gets really crispy put in the
fryer for about 15 minutes and then we
shall a kit with barbecue sauce ketchup
honey hoisin pie spice garlic ginger all
the classic flavors so this is like a
family style Chinese barbecue pork with
buns and coleslaw and hot mustard
about how many people desist him
anywhere from four to seven why does
that bun work with this pour I think
it's a perfect vehicle because it allows
using your hands without getting
hands dirty you get everything in there
the sauce the cole slaw crispy pork and
the unctuous soft pork all in a little
button do you have a specialist that
you're buying those ones from yeah it's
actually my cousin in Monterey Park
he owns a bakery so that's it
okay Cheers Steven
mmm-hmm we're drinking the pearl diver
oh I have nothing in my stomach right
now and I felt a jolt of that okay
perfect time to give you a knife come on
crack in there whoa whoa here I'll help
you out hold the meat down that's what
I'm talking about they're wrong that I
just want to eat this like a corn on the
cob whoa finger food I have a feeling
you're gonna love this hmm I'm gonna cut
you off Pete this meat right here okay
okay I'll help myself to a bun you know
come on Sam it needs a meat bun so touch
of that now look at my bun and look at
your buck because you're a gluttonous
Pig yeah I'm a big fatty you know the
big fatty the mustard oh no got a big
blob because I'm used to just dowsing my
hotdogs and mustard Cheers
this is perfect first of all anything
wrapped in a bun I'll eat this little
package has everything fatty meat is
also crispy powerful muscle if you feel
it in your nose oh yeah that's the
mustard scale 1 2 nose I think what's
the worry about this it's a push me spin
totally everything is so soft and then
you get it the skin it's like a lot of
the times a little sandwich you're
adding the texture from something else
but here the meat itself has all of the
textures represented this is the kind of
thing that I always see on the menu and
I'm like ooh I want to try that but I
can't order it by myself you know what
it reminds me no you want to like
basketball you have to get nine other
friends have to kind of like scrounge up
some people to kind of fill out the
table put some bench players coming to
dinner oh oh so a little fatty what do
you think it's fun to share a big piece
in there right yes sometimes you want to
feel like a little fatty right and I
definitely feel like a big fatty right
now you want to feel like something else
huh I don't know what to call this
factor you guys since I chose where
we're going I decided to do a little
research of myself and see how you like
my fat guy fact time the shift to a
cooked food diet may have been key to
the increase in brain size that occurred
in early human history
what's larger brains are more energy
expensive and cooking increases the
amount of energy that can be pulled from
food fossils show a decrease in the size
of human teeth around the same time that
brain size increased suggesting a shift
to eating softer higher quality foods
what you're saying is big brain a little
teeth I'm saying we became smarter when
we learned how to cook laughs you about
this facts are getting weirder the
restaurants are getting more arbitrary
and look did you eat good food already
today yeah that's all you need to know
it's gonna happen two more times worth
it
I'm Jody Friedman owner of Friedman's in
Silverlake daytime is new school Jewish
deli and then at night we have a full
cocktail bar the decor is really awesome
thank you loan away by the walk over
Thanks
today our chef Stef is going to be
showing you how to make our brisket
brisket is very much tied to Jewish food
and family celebrations
you always eat it on the holidays it's
usually kind of a homey dish our brisket
is not the sort of overly sweet like
traditional Jewish brisket the
presentation is like Jewish meets Texas
barbecue but the preparation I would say
is quite French actually we braised them
for three to four hours using burnt
onion garlic raw ginger that all goes in
via those are taken out cryovac and then
held we heat up in the cryovac bag so
it's this very very tender meat that
kind of falls apart and the sauce is
that ladle on top it's served with our
palm freeman which are like tater tots
MD pickles rye bread and smoked bone
marrow we wiill the brisket out on the
cart and cut it tableside using what we
call our dad knife electric saw with two
blades that go like that
yeah my dad has one of those there's
like yeah why that nice when you think
about how you would cut a brisket your
house you would be using a turkey cover
to pair that with a very formal
presentation of bringing it to a table
has this really nice dichotomy and
that's what Freedmen's is about you know
we have a great martini program but you
can always get a $5 hotdog at any time
of the day this is really beautiful
welcome to dinner Stephen what is this
it's a martini pickle juice pickle juice
oh yeah best pickle Lee martini I've
ever had the kick these are the palm two
Friedman I'm using my hands
okay radish Mayo who they like whipped
the texture of that was also very
surprising cherries I smell some of your
sauce there Adam try this it's like a
potato 3d Dorito yeah okay anywho that's
my Cola smooches here bone marrow oh my
god you want to bone me here it is dude
oh my god this is the literal meat of
the bone what up Oh
I'm gonna do a couple of pickles on here
cheers Steven they can meet adventure
I'm so happy mom a lot of these flavors
really make sense to me
I grew up in an Eastern European
immigrant households like pickles rye
bread a roast everything is just like
the perfect iteration of it
nothing is familiar yet everything is
familiar many times I've thought well
out to dinner I wish I could just make a
tiny sandwich of this food mmm here I
have that option you know I'm still
thinking about that saw I love it the
electric knife has this little light on
it it's both a spotlight and there's a
drumroll for your meat it's like here's
your meat
I got a shareable fruit this is just the
thing you can find all over Los Angeles
lime salt chili it's delicious I want
this pineapple right here Cheers
aah aah I was like lightening up my
mouth
so Friedman's delicious meat huh I want
to cut everything with that saw
you want to saw like that yes get for
Christmas do you hold this for me yeah
why cooking fat wait what hold my fruit
cooking fat hold my fruit cooking dance
so this is a continuation of early
humans cooking for the first time I like
it a two-parter putting the third better
nope research has shown that chimpanzees
possess many of the cognitive capacities
required to cook well such as preference
for cooked food and the collisions to
wait for cooked foods ancestral humans
could have shared the same abilities
whoa so you coming back to share these
big shareable meats with me as you know
some prehistoric origin stories Wow you
are quite the archaeologist thank you
let me hope to be kind of like a food
Indiana Jones one day a foodie Anna
Jones did you hear that okay you say
that again no I'm Adam Perry Lang here
at APO restaurant in Hollywood so
restaurants pretty new I noticed the
established date yeah on the menu in
1969 when I was born this is really a
culmination of my journey as a chef
beef is my thing I look the procurement
of it aging it you don't like to call it
a dry-aged room its own because it's not
necessarily dry all the time you want to
have the correct ratio of humidity and
wrapper a tional for me it's all in the
details and cooking in life I went to
blade smithing school just to make sure
that last point of contact for the
customer is perfect the taste is just so
different when you have army blade and I
like to do things with intention down to
making my own knives today we're gonna
do one of my signature dishes which is
the APL short rib with pickle salad one
of the key ingredients is actually to
slather it in ballpark mustard
I love tying in nostalgia into cooking I
put that mustard on very lightly just so
that the beef can brown underneath but
the outside can caramelize and make the
rub sticks or creates a crust the crust
carries flavor and a
the meat from drying out in the initial
stage do you define this as a smoked
meat is it barbecue or is it something
else
I call it wood fired cooking there's
good smoke in this bad smoke if you burn
too low all these different compounds
don't have the opportunity to get burnt
off into the atmosphere that's going on
the meat if there's gonna be any smoke
you want it to be very subtle and over
time I've put vinegar on this because
the vinegar dries and what's left is the
sour residue that creates a salivation
it gets your mouth excited and ready to
eat vinegars like nature's msg what
we're doing for this episode is kind of
a family-style meat was there an
intention there as a thing we're
completely fire brings people together
it's like celebratory like the family
roast I mean I think some of the best
things in life are made simply tada big
money big meats we look at the Blue
Dream cocktail but I got the mocktail
but we're both living the dream the big
meat dreamer you want to taste mine
oh yeah yours is way juicier can I point
something else yeah the booth smells
like meat it's leathering can I serve
you some meat please Wow look at how
tender this is I don't need to cut it I
can just pull it apart okay Cheers
it's like if pot roast and barbecue had
a baby it has like this delightful layer
of smokiness when you swallow it it
still is there yeah resident which part
of this meat is your favorite honestly
it's the crust I've never had a better
crust
usually it's more of a shell than a
flavor component but here it's actually
quite tender and there is like a rich
flavor of black pepper which I really
love oh my god this meat is just
surrendering to me I'm gonna just grab a
piece Oh Holy Smoke
it has surrendered to my fingers here
comes the pickle meat sandwich there is
something very beautiful about a plate
that comes with just meat and pickles to
me those are like the two core food
groups vegetables and protein pickle and
me that's the food group it's pickle
pickles and meat pickles on me I'm a
little lad who loves pickles in meat can
I just take this grab the bone see if
this falls apart
oh you got all the meats looks like my
wish is coming true oh my god that is
crazy this is not fat but it's squishy
like fat is this any less satisfying to
you than a state coz you can come to
this restaurant you get a very nice
state I would probably take the short
rib I think it for me depends on the day
of the week this feels like Sunday
evening shared meats there's also
something really great about having a
big table where everybody's eating and
they're all tasting the same thing you
know it's not like Oh mine's good how's
yours oh it's good we can look at each
other and we know what it tastes like
because it's in all of our mouths like
your brains connected through invisible
network well the meat matrix this may be
the ultimate group bonding experience
yeah forget experiment group meat
first episode back you feel good yeah
feel very full very satiated I don't
think I'll be eating meat for a day or
two but after that deep talk back to me
which shareable meat was the most worth
it to you at its given price I would
have to say little fatty an Wow
yeah they're all very good but little
fatties with under $30 plus it's a truly
chinese-american restaurant and I love
it
I think my worth it winner is Freedmen's
the best balance of a meat I'd love to
eat it on its own and a meat that's
gonna be great as a little sandwich
afterwards I took some of that meat home
turned it into a spaghetti sauce is
phenomenal and Adam who's you're worth
it winner Wow
good answer I'll accept it hey Annie
who's your worth it winner I thought
that one coming in actually she was
scarfing down the Freedmen's after we
left we're going to your neck of the
woods for next episode want to give us a
little sneak peak it rhymes with hurry
and it's a very bad basketball player
LeBron rules so we need to learn how to
share before we could cook and by the
way we're talking about possibly a
million years ago
why are your facts all about millions of
years ago it's when the best stuff
happens oh yes